if it seems like groceries and gasoline
have gotten at least a little bit
cheaper lately it's true they have
inflation was lower in May it's the 11th
straight month that prices are down and
that could mean that no more interest
rate hikes at least from now from the
Federal Reserve Nancy Cordes is at the
White House for us covering all this
Nancy good morning
Good morning Tony yes that's what we're
going to be watching today the Federal
Reserve is meeting again today to decide
whether to raise interest rates again
but most analysts now believe that
they're going to hit the pause button
thanks in part to those latest inflation
numbers from May which show that prices
are up just four percent from a year ago
and I say just because inflation has now
been cut by more than half since the
peak of 9.1 percent last June as we were
coming out of the pandemic now four
percent means that the prices for most
things are still going up just not as
quickly and the cost of some key items
is actually coming down gasoline for
instance is now about a dollar forty
less per gallon than it was at the peak
and the price of eggs dropped nearly 14
percent from April to may you may have
noticed that in the grocery store that's
a signal to the FED that 10 straight
interest rate hikes in a row have worked
to cool the economy somewhat and bring
down inflation and that the FED may not
need to do an 11th rate hike right now
good news of course anyone looking to
buy a car or a house now we're not
completely out of the woods when it
comes to inflation the FED would like to
see it at two percent not four percent
but the White House is still calling
this a win especially because lower
inflation is often paired with higher
unemployment which is something we
aren't really seeing right now Adriana
Nancy thanks so much